is one of our favorite voices on the
worldwide leader in sports and we
figured with the nfl season coming up
and i was seeing his tweets during the
college football weekend and i'm like
let's get this man back on the program
he's bomani jones how you doing bomani
good man how about you i'm doing great
uh your tweet about james franklin made
me laugh out loud literally like an
actual audible i don't like saying the
letters l-o-l
but you saying essentially that he's the
all-time great potentially goat
of winning games that the fan base
wants him fired in the middle of
that one is great it always like it's
not just man bad game from james
franklin we got to fire this guy and i'm
like hey man it wasn't that long ago
that we didn't think y'all was gonna
have a program at all they were trying
to shut the doors on everything you guys
have been to a rose bowl with him they
stay ready to fire him
and yet yes that was one of those games
in the middle of it where both teams
were struggling offensively and um
and penn state comes out with the w in
wisconsin where they're jumping around
for the first time in over 600 days it
really was
impressive but that tweet made me laugh
that was good
that was like you go say something about
my observations about jump around
i'll give you the floor
now it's just one of these things uh
when it comes to like dancing and stuff
white people got poor self-esteem like i
think white people think that all black
people can dance and that's not true
those of us who can't dance have been
shamed it's not dancing i can tell you
that firsthand but in the end of 1991
genesis put out this song called i can't
dance and i think that a lot of people
leaned in like you know what you're
right okay
so what and then house of pain six
months later puts out jump around and
they're like that's what we'll do we
will jump around
and not only will we jump around we will
receive clear instructions on when to
jump
you gotta answer man if that's like
that's what people have been waiting on
just somebody to give them a little guys
get up get up and get down that's it
it's very simple
the instructions are simple you're right
it's easy to follow gosh that is funny
man and we were talking before the show
that there's not many of the kids who
are in fact jumping around knowing who
and what and how old that song really is
they have no idea yeah no no like i was
telling somebody that
jump around is now
29 years old so like if you heard ohio
state playing hang on sloopy in 1994
that's what jump around is
hanging on
it's a similar
now it's a great analogy that's uh jones
here on the rich eisen show uh alabama
looked like um you know alabama and then
the question is is is or is this over is
this thing over already are we done are
we done now after this one i don't know
who or how like who's going to sneak the
win this year because if you're going to
beat alabama you're typically going to
sneak a win and the one guy that could
figure out how to sneak one was malzahn
but he's not there anymore at auburn and
i just can't
i never thought that a circumstance
would come up where what nick saban
would build first and foremost at
alabama was the new wide receiver you
and they just roll off they all look the
same like they're all built the same
they're all about six feet tall just
about devonta smith was a little smaller
for this but they're all about like 190
195 they're all strong like just tanks
and they're all always open and they
rather rolled off two or three of them
last year they could roll two or three
more back in it's just gonna go like
this every single year like they just
there is no drop off at any point with
them well did you see what nick saban
said about uh
mercer coming up this week i did not
they said that you have a different type
of offense
hey he's had trouble with that though
they played one of those years where
they had like an all-time great defense
i think it was 2012 they played georgia
southern at the end of the year yes and
when espn would want to put up the
statistics about how incredible
alabama's defense was they always had to
limit it to fbs competition because
georgia southern gave them the blues
with that triple option
and so they're going to win but it is
going to be they're going to have some
moments out there but they're just like
yo man what are we supposed to do with
this
it's a different kind of offensive team
is the exact quote from nick saban as
mercer is the one to take him on after
they just
pounded miami and you know i don't mean
to be that way obviously we're going to
be excited about a college football
season and everybody always is and it's
great fun to watch
um but i don't i don't know man i know
maybe georgia i mean what georgia just
did to clemson and and they don't play
each other till the sec championship
game but we're assuming is going to
already go down you know
they're gonna have to score some points
though like kirby gonna have to figure
out that playing saban 1.0 is not going
to be saving 2.0 and if they're not
going to have an offense that's
consistently scoring 30 40 points a game
i don't think they got enough offensive
speed out about
bomani jones here on the rich eisen show
what's the story line for you the nfl
season 2021
two days away man what do you got for me
on that that i really
i am curious number one honestly how the
patriots are going to look with mac
jones because
he's one of these guys that i felt like
is really hard to forecast because
nothing he did in college looked special
not that he was not good but the things
that jump off the screen for you about a
great college player that's not his game
it's like if it's going to work it's
just going to be that he's remarkably
efficient and it's hard to tell how well
somebody's going to do there in that way
but if he is halfway decent
i mean this is still bill belichick
right like this is still the patriots
they went and reloaded a bit and got
some guys like i want to see how they
wind up looking the other story is for
me sticking with quarterbacks in that
division i was a josh allen skeptic and
i guess to a degree i remain a little
bit of a josh island skeptic but if he
plays even close to as well as he played
last year
the rest of that squad is loaded they're
right up there with the chiefs in the
afc if he can maintain the level of play
that we saw from last year well at week
five in the same way that we're talking
about hey it's all about who wins
georgia alabama from you know for for a
game that we
are assuming will happen in december we
know week five it's bills and chiefs and
that'll be some sort of a back pocket
tiebreaker for one of these teams even
in a 17 game season
moving forward and um last year there
was a whole
coved hoo-ha based on the titans
getting covered and it messed with the
bill's schedule
and the bills and chiefs were were a
reconfigured game
that it didn't really feel like that was
the one where the chiefs ran it down the
bill's throat i think they they ran the
same running play like 90 times and just
jammed it right down buffalo's throat i
i i would proffer to say there could be
a different result this year but
that's basically what a lot of people
think the afc shooting match could be
for
yeah the best to me about buffalo is if
you get some heat on josh allen because
he panics like that's the part that i
question whether he can fix his
panickers in the panic forever but if he
reaches the point where when there is
heat and he can just stand in there and
make it happen it's trouble for
everybody well emmanuel sanders could be
that guy as well to be added to that mix
what do you think bomani jones of the
browns chances
in 2021 here i mean we all got the same
problem and it's that they're the browns
like it's if they're not the browns all
of our answers feel completely different
because it feels like we've been
hoodwinked you know just by the idea of
the browns before it's like with me in
the fountains you're not getting me to
fall for that again i don't care how
many pro bowls they have 53 pro bowlers
i'm not falling for this i've seen this
movie far too many times um but i am of
the belief that getting odell beckham
back helps a lot and will make a good
offense even better an offense that
really doesn't need to go the ball very
much and really should be relying on the
run and i think that's what they're
going to keep doing in that koopiak type
scheme um that they run up there that
plus the defense they seem to have like
they should be right up right up there
and i really feel like if they wore any
other jerseys that's the way that we
would talk about them
they just don't feel right well i mean
look
you're you're you're spot on on every
single thing that you just said right
there but it's a baker mayfield um world
that we're living in for cleveland and
and if he shows up
better this year than his improved
version last year they could be very
difficult to stop and odell
that was the part of the
conversation last year that just didn't
compute that team's better off without
odell he was doing his own thing
sometimes running routes that weren't
really there and baker tried to force it
in there and the minute he was gone
things kind of opened up
uh i i'm not gonna buy that i won't buy
that because he's such a difference
maker that odell winning comeback player
of the year to lead the browns i don't
know if that's pie in the sky stuff but
that would be something else
that would be something else bomani yeah
i feel like the only people who are
making those arguments about odell
beckham are people who are mediocre
themselves like only mediocre people try
to sit around and try to figure out how
it is that this excellent person is
actually bad for the larger operation
and i think that in media because
beckham is so flashy
that
we make assumptions about what it must
be like to play with him the guys that
play with him love him like it's not
like he's one of these guys who doesn't
work hard he grinds he's on it um and if
mayfield can't figure out how to do this
with beckham out there then the problem
is ultimately on mayfield but i think
that they go set up an offense that
doesn't require baker mayfield to do
very much and if he doesn't have to do
very much and just have to do those
things well i think that's something
that he can pull off
you know is the greatest teammate one of
the greatest teammates i've had is dion
and when he first came in to nfl network
you hear doyle he's dion he's flashy
he's this he's that
everybody loves a guy
playing
working with him i don't understand the
way the flashiness comes to be i guess
if somebody is more as is is an
individual
pounds a chest or something like that i
i that that suddenly your your viewed is
is not as you pointed out uh an
excellent part of the collective i don't
i don't
get that one even if you get a guy like
carol owens with a problem with carol
always wasn't that everybody hated them
is that some people hated them and the
rest of the guys loved them and then you
had an issue like if everybody could get
behind hating them it wouldn't be a
problem right there wouldn't be anything
that wound up being divisive but it kind
of like him work so hard and you know
he's gonna bring it every time and i
find especially with football players if
they know you're gonna bring it they'll
let a lot of stuff go
so um the right time with bomani jones
podcast host and uh commentator from
espn uh bomani jones here on the rich
eisen show uh who do you have as uh your
super bowl pick for this year what do
you have for me on that front i think
the chiefs are gonna win it all i think
the chiefs would have wanted last year
they had just tried out like five fat
dudes they got off the street to go
block like i'll never forget when i
turned on the super bowl and they did
the graphic with you know the offensive
line started with the chiefs and i saw
mike remember at left tackle and i
didn't recognize who anybody else was i
was like oh my god wrong
my pig is very wrong and my pick was
dead wrong now they when he got orlando
brown um i think trapper joel empty is
coming back from canada up their state
lines over and all of this they'll be if
they're better up front than they were
last year then i don't think anybody's
better than them
who do they beat then who comes out of
the nfc
i'm still leaning toward tampa bay on
that one they just have so many guys
it's i don't
look i tried to get out in front on the
tom brady is falling off thing in 2014
and all they did was win a super bowl so
i'm never doing that again and nobody
else is doing that again i'm just saying
we just can't keep expecting the 44 year
old guy however what he is now to keep
being as good as he was last year and
for a lot of the postseason last year he
was not good he was not good um against
the saints he was not good at a couple
of those other games like he
he still is tom brady but he is not like
2007 tom brady or anything like that and
so to keep asking that guy to produce on
a level that is to win a super bowl if
he can do it it's amazing he might not
be able to do it this year i'm not
saying he won't i'm just saying every
year might be the year and i've been
saying that for seven years
who's the team that could uh prevent him
then from getting back
oh my gosh if i look over there i mean
aaron rodgers doesn't still play for the
backers like everybody happy about it
but he is still over there and if he can
you know if they look anything like they
did last year i think they got a chance
i agree what about the uh cowboys though
what about them oh it'll be fun
it'll be fun like how much defense is
dan quinn going to bring because mike
nolan with them was just absolutely
dreadful particularly early in the year
um i don't think there's too much to
worry about when press got in the ankles
that was a broken bone and not a
ligament situation and so i think he
comes back okay i think they're going to
be able to put up points if they have a
competent defense then they'll win the
east and there'll be a team that has a
chance to beat everybody if they have a
good to very good defense then they have
a chance to win the nfc not that they
will but they have a legitimate chance
but monty jones i love your uh
opinionating and the way that you put it
into uh
into uh words it really is terrific
you're uh you're one of one sir and i'd
love to have you back on whenever you
wish thank you i appreciate it man i'm
here for you right back at you the right
time with bomani jones podcast bomani
jones here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here